[Applaudissements]
c'est pourquoi monsieur d'un grand bisou
vous aider à appeler un chat un chat
tous les forums gros bisous à c'est vrai
on voit plein désert la barbe à papa a
pas mal j'aime bien et partagent travaux
des chroniqueurs ya quand même je
voudrais dire quand même c'est quand
même bien que chez nous que ça arrive ça
y'a quand même on est en plein en train
de discuter avec des forains c'est
important il ya quand même un relou qui
accélère en ferrari doit c'est quand
même mal alors aux loups du jour tant
que c'est pas les chasseurs qui sont
venues des séries dont on pourrait
t'appeler frange à la machine à laver
car il ya un mois pierre jean charles
ans ont été accusés pour faire des
soirées clandestines à des ministres
d'ailleurs tu leur soit pour parler trop
qui nous met alors tranquille ou de la
politique
et voilà demain 17h49
quand vous êtes chez vous demain à 17h49
c'est la date le 5 mai 1821 il est mort
à 17h49 quand vous êtes chez vous 2
malades chez vous vous pensez à ça 17h49
il est mort il ya de mettre à bas
donc comme vous le savez ici atp mp on
respecte la culture l'histoire le
patrimoine tu trembles stéphane bern car
ici on pose les vraies questions de
l'histoire de france
c'est connu traquer tout riquiqui
napoléon chalencon les deux annonces
tiens ils sont au top si le docteur
antomarchi et on a on a mesuré le sexe
de l'empereur n'était pas énorme mais
bon trois vers gruissan tymen pas et je
donne cette amnésie aux dirigeants que
je vais les maoïstes au une belle par
mois en dehors du fait de savoir la
taille de son pénis j'aimerais servant
la taille de son racisme parce que son
propre personnage historique de la z
sans le prend pas par exemple on peut
faire le même jeu qui hier prenez cette
phrase qui a dit je suis blanc je suis
pour les blancs parce que je suis blanc
je n'ai pas d'autres raisons
et celle là est la bonne comment a t'il
at on pu accorder la liberté à des
africains à des hommes qui n'avaient
aucune civilisation qui ne savaient pas
seulement ce qui était la france alors
votre avis le pen ou napoléon la pole et
autres phrases le mal que font les juifs
ne vient pas des individus mais dans la
consultation même de ce peuple
ce sont des sauterelles et des chenilles
par les forums et les juifs qui ravage
la france alors à votre avis napoléon ou
hitler si j'en passe et des pires et
napoléon a aussi rétabli l'esclavagé
donc la semaine prochaine emmanuel
macron a décidé de repousser encore plus
loin le concept du en même temps
d'ailleurs france était bien faute aux
la question emmanuel macron peut-il
commémorer les deux la réponse est oui
car notre président est très sportive
comme vous pouvez le voir aujourd'hui
commémoration de la mort de napoléon et
dimanche commémoration de l'abolition de
l'esclavagé voilà une bonne semaine bon
courage monsieur le président à part ça
mon cher sirène aujourd'hui jamais
dérogé à la règle parce que c'est
difficile de débriefer de l'émission
dire que j'ai regardé tous ces faits
divers
et vu que j'ai pas envie d'être
chroniqueur dans faites entrer l'accusé
j'ai décidé de faire entrer un peu
l'imaginaire ici quand je vous regarde
tous les chroniqueurs je me pose des
questions
comment étiez-vous plus jeunes est ce
que j'en ai droit et met déjà les
piscines ce que guillaume chante ont
organisé des boules quand discipline
parce que gilles verdez traiter sa
maîtresse d'islamophobe
c'est le genre de question que je me
pose quand je vois une personnalité
publique ou quel est le jour où tout a
basculé
j'en ai fait un sketch et ça s'appelle
karma
[Musique]
je suis malheureux d'avoir si peu le mot
à offrir aux cadeaux tarina
dillon paul tollé les jeunes iront jouer
au ballon dans la maison pew
et puis c'est un peu près tout one phone
et sony
là
et là
mais à gauche ici
ici on va tourner à gauche
la prochaine ne sera à gauche
bon j'en ai marre arrêtez vous arrêtez
vous au côté depuis ce matin j'ai vu ni
de tourner à gauche et vous tournez à
droite comme ça au goûter de ma gueule
soit vous êtes obsédé sur la droite
c'est quelque chose je suis pas
concentré on va on repart
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
tomasi le grand physicien lavoisier rien
ne se perd tout se transforme je
l'embrassé
[Applaudissements]